[Musique]
voix
[Applaudissements]
celle ci
selon les échos m
buzek
[Musique]
au fil des siècles notre peuple a volé
menti et tuer jusqu'au jour où nous nous
sommes trouvés un oubli mais cette
noblesse ne provenaient pas d'un esprit
de chevalerie elle provenait d'un
comportement tueur est impitoyable
[Musique]
vrai pouvoir ne réside pas dans le fait
de partir en guerre
je devrais pouvoir résister dans la
compréhension qui sont vraiment les
ennemis que l'on combat
[Musique]
et de la manière dont on peut les
vaincre
[Musique]
je comprends que vous ayez envie de vous
battre
il ya d'autres façons d'accomplir votre
devoir tu veux moi
[Musique]
je n'arrive pas à croire que d'ici une
demi heure je ferai partie de
l'incroyable ligne et/ou dynastie le
domaine royaume on préfère royan mais
quoi
non c'est vrai je t'assure ne prend pas
pour toi
ils veulent juste avoir cité qu'une très
intéressée par l'argent dans le genre de
ma chère femme
une dernière chose ensuite tu fera
officiellement partie de la famille
[Musique]
à minuit tu vas devoir jouer un jeu
c'est notre façon à nous d'accueillir
les nouveaux membres de la famille ce
sont les règles du jeu je n'ai aucune
chance de gagner ça restait bien caché
jusqu'à lourdes mais bonne chance
[Musique]
je croyais que tu risquais rien il faut
que tu me crois
ils sont sûr de devoir te tuer avant le
lever du soleil
je sais que tu es là
[Musique]
si on ne trouve pas et qu'on accomplit
pas le rituel on est tous morts
je les trouvais
c'est vrai ce qu'on dit
les riches sont vraiment différents s'il
vous plaît assez coûteux que j'en
profite pour souhaiter la bienvenue à la
nouvelle série ringer samia gibrat sauf
toi jeune cpe dans qu'il en est encore
temps
pourquoi madame dumas schmidt
vous êtes en troisième c'est une année
très importante pour moi monsieur en
fait sa tête la nouvelle coupure on
dirait un vrai dans maintenant juste sur
le ballon calme-toi un peu je te
rappelle quand même que tu as 19 ans car
en double et plus de 7 fois d'accord que
tu as ton fils qui ont 6 0 juste à côté
ok c'est pas bien vous n'avez pas le
droit
sony c'est un taux de change et dort
aussi donc c'est toi quelque chose de
venir ici en fait j'aimerais toujours eu
envie de travailler
moi je veux bien être certain il ya
aucun problème assez juste faut pas me
prendre pour un con
yanis tu cherches au koala tu veux te
faire exclure direct dès le début de
l'année c'est ça mais je te préviens moi
j'ai pas tout lâcher
là tu es sur une mauvaise pente et c'est
trop dommage parce que moi je sais que
tu vaux mieux que ça et si je vais aller
pas mieux que ça
elle me suis déjà allé moi c'était
compliqué quand il avait dix huit mois
vous mettez des lettres et du français
ou de moi de vous suivez les
mathématiques c'est des clés parmi
toutes les clés qu'on essaiera de vous
donner pour que vous puissiez choisir
votre avenir
sérieusement dos et les fesses je
voulais des comptes à bout des banquiers
déjà qu'on est dans une ville de kara
dans un quartier de ker à et vous votre
idée c'est de regrouper tous ses fois
ensemble
c'est ça votre projet pour nous
oh
[Musique]
si on signe à saint denis s'est pas
complètement commencé mi rieur
d'arriver en retard à cause de la grève
ah oui à melen créé c'était une grève
air france et habite au bout de la rue
non j'avoue c'est là j'ai un peu abusé
je suis le commandant mcbride et je
m'efforce de joindre le docteur clifford
mcbride c'est le fils du docteur qui
vous parle
j'aimerais te revoir papa
je me souviens que regarder des films en
noir et blanc et que tu avais un faible
pour les comédies musicales
tu me faisais travailler mes mates
tu m'a inculqué la valeur du travail
sache que j'ai choisi un métier que tu
approuverait je consacre ma vie à
l'exploration spatiale et c'est à toi
que je le dois
[Musique]
il se produit là haut une crise d'une
ampleur jamais vue
on
il est possible que votre père soit
impliqué mon père est mort
qu'attendez vous de moi au juste
l'exploration n'est pas toujours une
noble entreprise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
devant visage et l'hypothèse que ton
père ne veuille pas qu'on le retrouve
[Musique]
et
nous avons un travail à faire
tu prêt je suis prêt